merci d'être avec nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure et l'une des hautes scènes
vice-présidents du groupe rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes indépendant
c'est le groupe des sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle on va évidemment
commencer en parlant de la réforme des
retraites selon les sondages une
majorité de Français sont comprés ce
matin à Rungis Emmanuel Macron a dit
sans remettre au bon sens des Français
disant que l'ensemble dans l'ensemble
les gens savent qu'il faut travailler un
peu plus longtemps est-ce qu'il y a pas
un peu de déconnexion de la part du
président de la République non parce que
je pense qu'il a il a raison c'est que
lorsqu'on demande un des efforts
supplémentaires aux français bien sûr
que même nous les premiers on n'a pas
forcément envie de travailler plus
longtemps et après on est tous
conscients que on ne peut pas résister
aujourd'hui à la baisse de la
démographie de notre pays faut juste
rappeler des chiffres en dans les années
70 nous avions trois actifs pour un
retraité aujourd'hui on est à 1,7 actifs
pour un retraité et si on ne fait rien
demain ça sera 1,2 actif pour un
retraité donc on voit bien que le
système est équilibré et que le risque
c'est pas à court terme mais le risque
c'est que notre système pas répartition
celui qui a été fondé et qui est le
fondement même de notre modèle social
s'écroule complètement parce que
déséquilibré financièrement mais sauf
que les Français vous avez l'impression
qu'il entend ça est-ce que réforme
contre les Français je pense qu'ils
l'entende qu'il ne soit pas d'accord
pour travailler plus longtemps c'est une
évidence on n'est pas dans le déni on
entend ce que les Français disent mais
ils sont aussi conscients que demain si
nous n'avons pas de système par
répartition de retraite par répartition
c'est la retraite par capitalisation qui
va arriver et la retraite par
capitalisation c'est quoi c'est ceux qui
ont les moyens tout au long de leur vie
de mettre de l'argent de côté pour leur
retraite pour le faire et ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens seront dans la pauvreté
et on le voit dans un certain nombre de
pays par capitalisation je ne suis pas
sûr aujourd'hui que le modèle
anglo-saxon soit le meilleur et c'est
pas celui en tout cas que les Français
veulent le texte n'a pas été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale l'article 7 n'a
même pas été examiné c'est un échec pour
la majorité présidentielle non je pense
que un échec avant tout de l'opposition
et d'ailleurs les syndicats l'ont bien
répété les syndicats poussaient aussi
les élus de la majorité et de
l'opposition à aller jusque jusqu'au
vote de ce texte au vote de cet article
7 et je pense que c'est un échec avant
tout de l'opposition qui a voulu faire
de l'obstruction avant même de débattre
sur des sujets majeurs je pense que les
Français ont envie de voir aussi les
députés les positions des députés et des
parlementaires en général sur un sujet
aussi majeur que celui de la réforme des
retraites nous nous poussions au sein de
la majorité présidentielle par
l'intermédiaire à la fois du
gouvernement mais aussi de la présidente
du groupe majoritaire Aurore berger nous
demandions effectivement d'accélérer
mais lorsque la nuque a déposé 18000
amendements sur les 20 000 que
comprenait ce projet de de loi on voit
bien qu'il y avait une volonté
d'obstruction les rappels au règlement à
répétition le vous mettez toute la nuque
dans le même sac
alors je mets pas toute la nuit dans mix
face dans le même sac pardon parce que
effectivement je vois que les
socialistes et une grande partie des
écologistes ont voulu jouer le jeu et on
retirait des amendements et les
communistes également mais on voit bien
que la LFI qui est le premier groupe de
de la nuque avait une volonté
d'obstruction et organisée en fait les
débats pour qu'on n'arrive pas jusqu'au
vote de cet article 7 et que le vote de
la loi en général vous l'auriez remporté
le vote de cet article 7 on n'avait
aucun doute là-dessus moi j'ai aucun
doute sur la capacité à la masse pour la
majorité présidentielle avoir du bon
sens et à faire en sorte que et les
républicains et les indépendants et les
bien sûr les groupes de la majorité
présidentielle puisse aller dans dans
cette volonté d'équilibre encore une
fois de notre système de retraite par
répartition le texte va arriver au Sénat
la semaine prochaine vous pensez qu'au
Sénat il y aura la place pour un débat
de fond
je pense que déjà historiquement au
Sénat on corrige souvent les
excentricités de l'Assemblée nationale
on est dans une sagesse et on est moins
dans la posture politicienne et donc les
débats de fonds vont s'organiser ça déjà
commencé avec un certain nombre
d'auditions on a aussi eu des débats au
sein de la commission des affaires
sociales notamment donc moi je crois
vraiment au débat parlementaire je pense
que l'article 7 ici je souhaite je
souhaite et je pense qu'on peut y
arriver si effectivement les groupes
d'opposition et notamment sur la
question sur la gauche de l'hémicycle ne
joue pas l'obstruction et mais je pense
que vraiment la position aujourd'hui des
syndicats qui demandent ce débat et que
qui demande ce vote vont aussi
convaincre notamment le président kaner
qui était plutôt tenté sur une
obstruction et ralentissement des débats
je pense que il risque d'être convaincus
par les par les syndicats d'aller
jusqu'au vote jusqu'au vote final je
suis cote de l'article 7 ou je pensais
que le débat il reste jusqu'au bout et
jusqu'au vote final quel est l'intérêt
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas être
parlementaire et se dire que on ne veut
pas voter une loi et on fait de
l'obstruction si on croit à l'utilité du
Parlement il faut qu'on ait le débat qui
peut bien sûr montrer des désaccords il
y aura des désaccords mais quel est
l'intérêt d'un parlementaire si on ne va
pas jusqu'au vote d'un article et
jusqu'au vote de la loi c'est notre rôle
c'est pour ça que l'on a été élu c'est
pour ça que les Français nous ont élu et
nous ont fait que nous ont fait
confiance et donc il faut qu'on aille
jusqu'au bout est-ce que votre groupe le
groupe RDP va déposer des amendements
est-ce qu'il y a des choses à corriger
dans ce texte selon nous mais il y a des
il y a des choses à corriger il y a des
choses à améliorer parce que le débat
quand même le peu de débats qui a eu à
l'Assemblée nationale en tout cas quand
on était sur des débats de fonds il y a
eu des améliorations et donc tout ça n'a
pas forcément été repris puisque c'était
le texte initial qui est ressorti
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de vote donc je
pense qu'il y a des éléments nouveaux à
reprendre sur la question de la
pénibilité sur la question de l'index
senior moi je suis très attentif aussi
sur
réintégrer dans le texte à titre
personnel on aura la discussion bien sur
un groupe moi j'ai la chance d'être chef
de fil sur sur ce texte avec Martin
lévrier pour le groupe RDPI on portera
un certain nombre d'amendements et puis
et puis aussi au-delà des amendements il
y a aussi des débats sur lesquels on
doit porter la position de la majorité
président au sein je vous dis encore une
fois sur la question de la pénibilité
sur la question de l'index senior sur
laquelle vous allez faire sur la
pénibilité renforcer réintroduire des
critères les critères les critères déjà
qui sont dans les dans le texte initial
je pense que c'est important sur la
question aussi des charges lourdes voilà
il y a un certain nombre de
d'outils qui ont été proposés qui ont
évolué aussi dans le débat parlementaire
et qu'il va falloir continuer et
intégrer il y a aussi des questions sur
les carrières longues le groupe horizon
vendredi à quelques heures de la fin de
l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale a déposé un amendement pour
dire que les Français qui sont dans un
dispositif carrière longue ne doivent
pas travailler plus de 43 ans quel que
soit l'âge auquel ils ont commencé à
travailler vous êtes d'accord avec ça
c'est un sujet qui qui effectivement
une majorité présidentielle on
demande des efforts mais effectivement
il faut que les efforts soient partagés
et lorsqu'on a travaillé plus longtemps
quand on a commencé sa carrière tôt
c'est aussi normal qu'on puisse partir
plus tôt c'était d'ailleurs dans le
texte initial du gouvernement porté par
Olivier dupes il y a eu des avancées
notamment entre la commission à
l'Assemblée nationale et l'hémicycle et
notamment l'engagement de la première
ministre sur les carrières longues à
partir enfin en dessous de 21 ans donc
entre 20 et 21 ans on voit bien qu'on
était sur 43 annuités donc maintenant je
pense que le débat avant tout le monde
là le problème c'est que vous avez
commencé à 16 ans vous êtes avec 44 ans
à 17 ans 43 1844 est-ce que il y a pas
un problème est-ce que il faut dire plus
personne ne travaille plus de 40 ans je
pense qu'il faut évoluer il faut qu'on
voit l'équilibre mais effectivement il
faut qu'on ait une ligne rouge sur cette
question derrière la réforme des
retraites c'est quoi la ligne rouge
c'est l'équilibre budgétaire c'est faire
en sorte que demain nous puissions
financer les retraites aujourd'hui que
nous finançons les retraites de nos
retraités actuellement et que demain
nous puissions pérenniser ce système de
retraite baisse du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités donc ils font un équilibre
budgétaire si nous nous engageons
effectivement à avoir une uniformité sur
les 43 annuités il faut bien qu'on
trouve des recettes supplémentaires
autre part ou des dépenses sociales et
donc c'est tout le débat parlementaire
que nous allons mener à la fois en
commission et dans l'hémicy qui nous
permettront d'avancer là-dessus est-ce
que ça signifie que le fait que le
groupe horizon qui appartient la
majorité présidentielle dépose cet
amendement qui a des fissures au sein de
la majorité mais il y a pas de fissure
au sein de majorité on est tous d'accord
sur l'objectif après qui est des débats
le rôle d'un parlementaire c'est de
proposer on n'est pas des Playmobil
comme on nous a pu on a pu nous accuser
à un moment donc on est là pour proposer
on est là pour débattre et je pense que
c'est tout à fait sain aujourd'hui que
les parties de la majorité puisse faire
des propositions et ensuite c'est
l'ensemble de la majorité présidentielle
et de la majorité parlementaire qui
pourra effectivement valider ou non les
propositions vous êtes membre du groupe
d'études sur le handicap ici au Sénat
est-ce que vous soutenez Bruno
Retailleau qui dit que il faut une
pension de réversion pour les enfants
handicapés
je pense qu'effectivement il faut
avancer là-dessus c'est une bonne
proposition moi je porte ces questions
sur le sur le handicap je pense qu'il
faut revoir aussi sur la question des
adultes handicapés c'est à dire que
lorsqu'il n'y a plus les parents les
adultes handicapés se retrouvent seuls
et la question de la pension de
réversion effectivement est un bon moyen
peut-être d'accompagner ces adultes
handicapés et donc je pense que le débat
va être intéressant et si il est mené
dans l'hémicycle que je pense que je le
soutiendrai en tout cas on aura le débat
le gouvernement et est aussi très
attentif à ces questions là moi j'en ai
parlé plusieurs fois avec le ministre du
soft et je pense qu'il est très attentif
aussi aux différentes propositions donc
je pense que la proposition de Monsieur
rotao du président Retailleau va dans le
bon sens un dernier mot puisque en plein
examen du texte Sénat le 7 mars les
syndicats appellent la mettre la France
à l'arrêt le 9 mars sur un mouvement de
la jeunesse ça vous inquiète
on est déjà on n'est jamais heureux de
me voir la France à l'arrêt je ne suis
pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui ça soit la
proposition qui est des manifestations
c'est tout à fait légitime moi je
défends le droit de grève et d'ailleurs
je me suis exprimé sur votre plateau
contre la proposition de limiter ce
droit de grève mais maintenant il faut
aussi que le débat parlementaire puisse
avoir lieu on va arriver au Sénat dans
l'hémicycle à partir du 2 mars il faut
que le débat puisse avoir lieu il faut
qu'on puisse aller jusqu'au vote et
ensuite
il faut pouvoir l'appliquer et
convaincre les Français qu'elle cette
réforme est nécessaire on va parler d'un
autre sujet avec nos partenaires de la
presse régionale de la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie puisqu'il y
a eu un premier vote dimanche pour en
parler on va à Montpellier on retrouve
Vincent Coste bonjour Vincent merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Vincent
journaliste Midi Libre et Vincent vous
revenez dans vos pages sur ces travaux
de la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie
oui tout à fait c'est ces travaux 180
personnalités personne de la société
civile donc qui ont travaillé sur sur
cette question très très sensible et qui
sont arrivés effectivement cette
conclusion à une grande majorité pour
80% d'entre eux que le cadre actuel posé
par la loi clinique Leonetti n'était pas
suffisant qu'il fallait aller de qu'il
fallait aller de l'avant
ont été mis sur la table les questions
d'euthanasie de suicide assisté
la présidente de cette commission a
évoqué un tournant je souhaitais
demander au
sénateur aujourd'hui présent sur votre
plateau qui représente la majorité
justement à la fois son avis sur ses sur
ce travail et sur le rendu de cette les
conclusions de cette de cette
consultation citoyenne s'il était en
s'il était en phase avec avec ses
conclusions et surtout si considérait
qu'on était un tournant qu'effectivement
on ne pouvait plus rester en état
qu'effectivement il fallait envisager
une évolution du cadre juridique actuel
bonjour écoutez moi à titre je vous
réponds à titre personnel et aussi au
nom du parti politique dans lequel
j'appartiens à titre personnel moi c'est
un combat qui m'est cher depuis le début
de mon mandat depuis 2017 c'est vraiment
une question sur lequel je me suis
engagé j'ai toujours soutenu cette cette
aide active à mourir et c'était à mourir
dans la dignité et donc c'était un
combat que que je menais avec une amie
qui m'était très chère Chantal Maismont
qui nous a quitté cette année et qui
était vice-présidente de notre parti
territoire de progrès et qui menait ce
combat et depuis 2019 nous avons
effectivement pris l'engagement à
territoire de progrès donc cette
composante de la majorité présidentielle
avec renaissance de porter ses
propositions et donc il y avait à la
fois une attente forte des Français et
qui sait d'ailleurs concrétisé dans dans
cette convention citoyenne et je pense
une nécessité aussi que la
représentation nationale et le pouvoir
politique puisse se saisir de cette
question et moi je salue la décision du
Président de la République de lancer
cette convention citoyenne non pas sur
seulement s'appuyer sur des sondages qui
étaient effectivement très favorable
quoi 86 % des Français étaient
favorables à cette question d'aider à
mourir dans la dignité mais aussi
s'appuyer sur des faits réels et donc
avec la ministre Firmin le Baudot qui
fait aujourd'hui le tour d'Europe avec
un certain nombre de parlementaires dont
je fais partie pour voir les
législations les évolutions des autres
pays de nos pays voisins il y a aussi
cette volonté d'accompagner à la fois la
le réel accompagnement et on a un vrai
question aussi sur les soins palliatifs
dans notre pays 26 départements je
rappelle 26 départements métropolitains
n'ont pas d'unité de soins palliatifs
c'est une catastrophe dans notre pays et
donc il faut à la fois mettre les moyens
et il y a une volonté de la ministre
Firmin libodo pour mettre une vraie
stratégie à partir du mois de juin sur
la question des soins palliatifs et
quelque chose qui n'est pas en
opposition mais le fait de d'accompagner
aussi
cette aide active à mourir dans la
dignité je pense que c'est une bonne
mesure il va falloir maintenant le
transcrire à l'échelle législative et ça
c'est tout le débat tout le lien de la
responsabilité maintenant des
parlementaires que nous sommes et en
tout cas moi à titre personnel c'est
quelque chose que je suivrai fortement
et que je soutiendrai et que je
déposerai si nous n'avons pas au bout
d'accord on sait justement vous évoquez
votre votre position personnelle mais on
sait que c'est position vont souvent
au-delà des des clivages politiques
traditionnels vous avez parlé de ce
qu'il en était pour pour votre formation
pour territoire de progrès mais dans la
majorité en général dans le bloc
majoritaire en
général qu'elle est cette opposition est
partagée ça fait l'unanimité au
contraire il y a des lignes de fracture
possible mais mais comme pour tous les
sujets qui touchent à l'intime ça
dépasse les clivages politiques c'est
encore une fois comme c'est une question
très personnelle sociétale je pense que
la liberté de vote doit aussi et la
liberté de conscience doit pouvoir
s'exprimer et c'est normal il n'y a pas
forcément une unanimité chez les
républicains il y a pas forcément une
unité de la majorité présidentielle il a
pas forcément d'uneanimité aussi à
gauche mais ce qui est important c'est
qu'on puisse écouter aussi à la fois la
tente des Français l'évolution aussi de
la société qu'on n'en est pas non plus
un village gaulois donc il faut voir
aussi l'évolution législative dans les
pays voisins les pays européens et donc
avancer sur cette question qui est
nécessaire aujourd'hui il n'est plus
possible que lorsque moi je crois à la
liberté je crois à la liberté de choisir
sa fin de vie et je crois à cette
liberté de ne pas mourir aussi seul et
c'est malheureusement ce qui se passe
dans trop souvent quand on est obligé
d'aller dans d'autres pays européens
pour pour choisir de mourir dans la
dignité et donc toute cette évolution
législative doit AB outir et je pense
que on arrivera à trouver une large
majorité parlementaire sur ce sujet
merci Vincent Coste merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous la une du Midi
Libre aujourd'hui une France bientôt
c'est la Question à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Vincent d'avoir
été avec nous on passe à l'actualité
votre actualité au Sénat Xavier puisque
vous avez déposé une proposition de loi
pour immatriculer vélo et trottinette on
en parle tout de suite avec Alex tout ça
et Alex est-ce qu'aujourd'hui cet usage
des trottinettes est déjà encadrée par
la loi alors c'est des gens encadré hein
depuis 2019 il y a un décret qui régule
l'utilisation des trottinettes il fixe à
12 ans l'âge minimum de conduite limite
à leur vitesse à 25 km/h et puis il
interdit la circulation sur les
trottoirs ou rend obligatoire la
présence de feux de position sur ces
engins mais malgré cet encadrement il a
quand même beaucoup de dérives et puis
aussi un des accidents mortels chaque
année notamment en France une trentaine
d'accidents mortels en 2022
la mairie de Paris va proposer aux
habitants d'interdire les trottinettes
en libre-service et oui la maire de
Paris Anne Hidalgo organise une
consultation citoyenne pour voir si les
Parisiens sont favorables à
l'interdiction pure et simple des
trottinettes électriques en
libre-service à Paris d'autres grandes
villes l'ont déjà fait comme Barcelone
et Montréal qui ont interdit ces engins
motorisés Lisbonne a divisé leur nombre
par 2 limiter leur vitesse à 20 km/h et
des comme Stockholm et Oslo sont aussi
sur la voie de mesure restrictives comme
celle-ci vous avez lacovelli en quoi
interdire purement et simplement la
trottinette en libre-service à Paris ce
serait une fausse bonne idée déjà moi je
pense que quand on ne sait pas gérer on
interdit et je pense que c'est difficile
aujourd'hui d'assumer une impuissance
publique une impuissance du pouvoir
politique alors même que cette forme de
mobilité douce a été promu fortement par
la Mairie de Paris et moi je suis
favorable encore une fois assez
mobilités douces ça va dans le bon sens
c'est une demande à la fois des citoyens
c'est une ville comme une ville comme
Paris c'est une ville très touristique
et donc qui qui accueille énormément de
touristes qui utilisent aussi
cette trottinette électrique en
freefluting et donc je ne pense pas que
la solution soit d'interdire je pense
qu'il faut réguler il faut réorganiser
le partage de l'espace public je note
juste d'ailleurs que vous êtes venus
entretien
et donc vous ne serez pas concerné sur
doigt et cette immatriculation
obligatoire
et quoi et de faire en sorte de à la
fois de responsabiliser les utilisateurs
de ces engins parce que en fait on le
voit bien aujourd'hui quand on est en
vélo électrique quand on est en
trottinette électrique on pense être
au-dessus des règles du code de la route
bah oui mais quand on est en vélo
électrique ou en trottinette électrique
oui on respecte on s'arrête au feu rouge
c'est juste c'est une question de bon
sens en fait c'est même pas on est plat
pour réinventer l'eau chaude il est
question de bon sens et il est question
de donner aussi la possibilité à nos
forces de l'ordre aux élus locaux qui
sont très demandeurs encore une fois de
régulation de de cette usiliation de
mobilité douce de leur donner les moyens
d'agir sur le terrain et donc
l'immatriculation n'est pas la solution
miracle pour baisser l'accidentologie
mais c'est un moyen d'action pour
réguler responsabiliser parce que je
rappelle encore une fois que ceux qui
sont les premières victimes de ces
engins c'est les utilisateurs eux-mêmes
vous parliez effectivement une trentaine
en 2022 on est mais une évolution c'est
à dire il avait 7 en 2020 22 en 2021 on
est une trentaine en 2022 rien que dans
mon département sur 18 décès d'accidents
de la route 3 étaient dû à des
trottinettes électriques donc on voit
bien qu'il y a un besoin aujourd'hui de
sécuriser de protéger ses utilisateurs
et de faire en sorte aussi de repartir
sur la base de ce qui était la loi
Badinter c'est-à-dire le piéton a
toujours raison et le piéton doit être
aussi protégé et on voit bien que
l'utilisation des trottinettes
électriques et des vélos électriques
peut aussi provoquer un certain nombre
d'accidents mortel pour deux ou de
blesser je rappelle 6000 blessés rien
que sur Paris Lyon Marseille en 2022 et
notamment des piétons évidemment sur
cette question de la sécurité et ce
qu'il faut aller vers un port du casque
obligatoire pour ses engins motorisés
comme et bien le port de la ceinture de
sécurité est obligatoire
c'est alors moi j'ai pas souhaité le
maître dans la proposition de loi
pourquoi parce que en déposant cette
proposition de loi ça nous permet
d'ouvrir le débat et dans le cadre d'une
proposition de voix par voie
d'amendement il y a la question
effectivement du casque obligatoire qui
pourrait aboutir il y a la question de
l'assurance aussi personnelle sur
l'utilisation de ces engins je parle ce
n'est pas d'ailleurs uniquement les
trottinettes en libre-service c'est
aussi les trottinettes personnelles
motorisées que nous pouvons avoir
acheter et qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 25
km/h donc c'est ce n'est pas anodin en
fait comme comme vitesse comme vitesse
et donc effectivement je pense que le
débat parlementaire doit pouvoir aboutir
à un certain nombre de questions
d'encadrement de régulation et de
protection avant tout des utilisateurs
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui utilisent
ces engins motorisés est-ce qu'il faut
aller aussi vers une question et un
système de formation pour pouvoir les
utiliser formation à ces engins et aux
règles qui sont en vigueur et qui ne
sont pas forcément reconnus des jeunes
des jeunes utilisent par exemple des des
scooters de moins de 50 cm3 il y a bien
une formation initiale et donc oui
peut-être qu'il faut aller jusqu'au la
législation qui permettait d'interdire à
moins de 12 ans l'utilisation de ces
véhicules peut-être doit aussi renforcer
l'utilisation on a aussi une
interdiction d'avoir deux personnes sur
une trottinette et pourtant on le voit
dans nos villes aujourd'hui que
notamment les jeunes utilisent à deux et
donc c'est extrêmement dangereux c'est
trottinette donc oui il faut évoluer et
moi je crois au débat parlementaire et
je pense que on pourra avoir un débat de
qualité un débat de fond avec les élus
locaux notamment moi j'ai fait avant de
cette proposition de loi j'ai fait le
tour aussi d'un certain nombre de maires
qui sont demandeurs d'avoir une
législation plus renforcée pour protéger
et partager l'espace public et justement
dernier modèle et oui est-ce que vous
vous savez déjà quand va être examiné au
Sénat votre proposition de loi et
comment elle est accueillie a priori par
la majorité de droite du Sénat
alors elle est déjà cosignée par un
certain nombre de parlementaires quand
je l'ai proposé à cause signature sur
tous les bancs de notre hémicycle il y a
eu une très bonne réception donc on voit
bien que ça dépasse les clivages
partisans y compris dans mon département
des maires qui ne sont pas de ma
formation politique soutiennent cette
proposition je sais que le ministre des
Transports Clément Beaune il est très
favorable et veut avancer dès le mois de
mars sur la question des mobilités
douces et donc peut-être que on arrivera
pas sur un point de vue législatif
peut-être que la question réglementaire
pourrait régler cette question là avant
même l'été mais dans tous les cas si on
ne va pas sur quelque chose de
réglementaire qui vient de la part du
gouvernement nous pourrons peut-être
nous avons une niche parlementaire au
mois de juin et j'espère pouvoir pour
l'inscrire avant l'été sur cette niche
parlementaire merci Alex pour
avoir tous c'est ça
sécurité en toute sécurité on va voir ça
en toute sécurité on vous regarde partir
Alex merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure
un dernier mot sur les sénatoriales
exagéré puisque vous faites partie des
départements renouvelables vous serez
candidat peut-être de liste je suis
candidat aujourd'hui investi par le
parti Renaissance oui effectivement ce
sera une liste Renaissance ou une liste
Renaissance horizon modem moi je
souhaite que ce soit une liste majorité
présidentielle aujourd'hui on a tout
intérêt à se rassembler on travaille
ensemble depuis 2017 on a fait toutes
les élections en commun et c'est
aujourd'hui la volonté à la fois du
président de la République et des
présidents des différents des
différentes formations de la majorité
présidentielle donc oui nous nous irons
en tout cas sur une recherche sur
l'ensemble des départements à avoir des
listes communes de la majorité
présidentielle et même élargir parce que
la question sénatoriale ce n'est pas
seulement une question d'étiquette
politique c'est une question aussi de
personnel sur les territoires et de
rassemblement le plus large possible un
dernier mot est-ce que vous souhaitez
briller la présidence du groupe à la
suite de François Patriat donc je pense
que la question de se pose pas je suis
vice-président du groupe majorité
présidentiel au Sénat
j'ai pleinement confiance
au président Patriat le président a été
élu il y a maintenant un peu moins de
trois ans il n'est pas renouvelable en
2000 en 2023 et donc il a vocation à
être notre président en trois ans
supplémentaires et je le soutiens
pleinement moi je fais mon travail en
tant que vice-président du groupe et
c'est vraiment ma seule volonté
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup Xavier merci
d'avoir été notre invité dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoire on parlera
du régionalisme est-il une menace pour
l'unité de la République ce sera notre
débat entre Benjamin Morel et Frédéric
Berry le président de la collectivité
européenne d'Alsace et puis on ira en
Bretagne à Vitré exactement mais d'abord
on va accueillir notre prochain invité
politique c'est un homme Muselier qui
nous rejoint